we need to remain vigilant and avoid
escalation
ministers made clear
any future russian aggression
would come at a high price
and have serious political and economic
consequences for russia
ministers made clear that we stand by
our decisions
our support for the sovereignty and
territorial integrity remains unwavering
and the message is that is only ukraine
and 30 nato allies that decides when
ukraine is ready to join nato russia has
no veto russia has no say and russia has
no right to establish a severe influence
trying to control their neighbors we
don't know whether president putin has
made the decision
to invade
we do know that he is putting in place
the capacity to do so on short order
should he so decide
so despite uncertainty about intentions
and timing
we must prepare for all contingencies
while working to see to it that russia
reverses course we've made it clear to
the kremlin that we will respond
resolutely
including with a range of high-impact
economic measures that we've refrained
from using in the past we call on all
sides to restore the ceasefire to july
2020 levels
and we urge russia to de-escalate
to reverse the recent troop buildup
to return forces to normal peacetime
positions to pull back heavy weapons and
forces from the line of contact in
eastern ukraine
to refrain from further intimidation and
attempts to destabilize ukraine
internally and to leave plans for
further military action behind and quite
frankly it's
um it's perplexing because the idea
that ukraine represents a threat to
russia
is uh would be a bad joke if things
weren't so serious
in light of the destabilizing actions
taken by the lukashenko regime the north
atlantic council has suspended
cooperation with belarus
the united states is preparing
additional sanctions in close
coordination with the european union and
other partners and allies
we call on the regime to immediately
stop using migrants as political weapons
we will hold the regime accountable for
its ongoing disregard for democracy
for human rights for the rule of law
taking into account the gravity of the
threat that a potential new
russian invasion in ukraine poses
the european continent may be at a very
critical juncture right now
we believe it is necessary to show
strength
in order to avoid the need to be proving
it later the open question is
the extent and the volume of these
sanctions
this is the most tricky issue and then
there will be the moment of truth
hopefully hopefully we will avoid the
need to actually impose them and the
very fact that these sanctions are
prepared will be sufficient uh
deterrence measure for russia to think
twice
and put the military option aside
but of course if russia decides to
conduct another big military operation
in ukraine and eu is to make a decision
and that decision has to be made by
consensus
i think that
there will be no country that will be
able to oppose this decision
having a big war
in its background yesterday i was with
the prime minister of ukraine in
brussels
today we'll meet the foreign affairs
minister
and in both cases
i want to stress that for the european
union
the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of ukraine
is above anything
and we will be
standing firmly and decisively
with ukraine
in front of any attempt to undermine
its territorial integrity and
sovereignty everything has to be done in
order to make clear
that any aggression against ukraine will
have a
strong response
and that's what we're going to talk
today here also